[Music]
tonight odd Brian Ross investigates the
war of the D'Amato's their wedding was
big news former US senator Alphonse
D'Amato down the aisle with his new
younger wife cateura now they're back in
the headlines with an explosive lawsuit
watch the nanny cam video that she says
proves he tried to use his influence
with the police to get her locked up in
the psych ward plus the White House now
turning into a real-life game show you
fired go you're fired
you're fired I mean this administration
has more staff turnover than a Walmart
on Black Friday we're joined live by
former homeland security secretary
Ranveer's plus our shoutout inside one
of the country's private prisons the
chaos and violence exposed by a reporter
who went undercover after being hired as
a guard for $9 an hour if you have a
driver's license and are breathing and
are willing to work that were willing to
hire you from the law and crime Network
studios in New York City this is Brian
Ross investigates good evening and
welcome tonight a man with great power
now accused by his wife of using that
power to get her thrown in the psych
ward with allegations of big money
financial chicanery thrown in all part
of an explosive lawsuit it's the case of
keturah D'Amato against Alphonse D'Amato
the former three-term Republican US
senator from New York they were married
15 years ago Alphonse D'Amato had
already left the US Senate but remained
a figure of power and influence in New
York politics I went in this County gets
elected or appointed without his input
now the D'Amato's are at war divorce is
pending and the fight over custody of
their two children has turned very ugly
I feel really foolish and I didn't see
it but he kept a lot of stuff secret in
a federal civil rights lawsuit filed
last month mrs. thibedeaux claims her
husband used his influence with local
police and authorities to falsely
imprison her for three days against her
will at a local hospital psychiatric
ward all to gain an advantage in the
custody case they ended up taking you
away cause you were confined for three
days is this you think because your
husband has the kind of clout they'll do
whatever he wants I know it is it all
goes back to an incident at kotora de
Matos home involving police in September
2017 the senator's wife showed us clips
from nandi cameras set up around her
home that she says back up her claims
this is the model says she initially
called police because she thought she
might have seen a prowler on a back deck
at one point at least five officers from
the Nassau County Police Department were
inside the house apparently concerned
there was a weapon somewhere in the
house the 9-1-1 operator said are there
any weapons in the house
I said yes there is a lawful eeper there
is a shotgun lawfully purchased
locked and secured in my office closet
with her arm in a sling from recent
surgery the surveillance camera clips
show her pointing police to the closet
where the gun was stored and that an
officer removing the gun still in its
original packing de Matos wife says her
81 year old husband Alphonse who soon
emerges in his pajamas
then lobbied police to say she could be
a danger to herself or others
because of the gun and because he said
she was crazy off her drugs he lied
about several things but he started out
by saying oh she's crazy you know she's
crazy and so on Tom Liotta is Catherine
de Matos lawyer he then said she takes
lithium and you know we all know that
lithium is generally taken for a bipolar
disorder which she does not have does
she take lithium no she takes she just
takes ritalin for a condition that she
said since she was a child which is ADHD
an attention deficit disorder that's all
she's got but the senator said she takes
lithium right and then she's crazy yes
and and he also said that she had a
psychiatric history which she doesn't
have not at all not at all these are all
lies fabrications by him and this this
is what led to the police taking her to
the hospital
because with what senator D'Amato said
to the police absolutely that's what
happened he just made that up he just
made it up
all of this has been playing out in the
courts in Nassau County where D'Amato
first began in politics
and is still a revered figure here when
I caught up with him shortly before the
lawsuit was filed he said he was just
trying to protect his children from his
wife who he said had a frightening
episode
[Music]
we appeared anyway
and anybody would suggest that actually
mistaken its for Italy and I shouldn't
be penalized because I thought the
tremors finish yes my mom many things
but the fact of the matter is
additionally
I asked him if he had tried to get the
police to think his wife was crazy on
the night they came to the house the
tenors are you've heard that successful
that's repulsive
this is D'Amato was watching as I talked
with her husband and heard his claim
that she had had a frightening encounter
the only frightening thing that happened
that evening was the way he corrupted
the police officers and got them to do
something which they all know was not to
be done so it's really not inappropriate
so you're still fighting still fight as
alfonse d'amato left in his chauffeured
car we could all see the VIP license
plate on the back number eight a symbol
of the power and influence he still
wields in New York State we asked in
order de Matos lawyer to come out our
program or offer any comment we've not
heard back the offer remains open but
joining us now is Thomas Lodi
at hora de Matos lawyer who filed this
most recent lawsuit against the former
senator mister lady thank you very much
for being here Brian thank you for
having me it's a real pleasure this is
the model talks about the secrets that
he kept and is a reference in the
lawsuit to forged checks what's that all
about well it's about the fact that in
2013 and 14 she found an account where
mr. D'Amato had forged her name to it
and forged her name to certain checks
here they are those offenders think
about that and that's not her signature
no that's not our signature these are
forgeries and unfortunately it had 39
million dollars in that account
which he had used for campaign
contributions and personal expenses
that's a crime isn't it - for to check
absolutely a crime and should be
investigated and prosecuted is the FBI
looking into this for the FBI is looking
at it and hopefully as a result of this
broadcast they're going to move off a
dime here and do something about it
because it really needs to be done
mr. Gowdy there's also another video
that mrs. D'Amato made while she was in
the hospital recovering from shoulder
surgery so in the former senator in a
tirade against her shouting about her
with profanity
[Music]
I'm leaving what's that all about she
had spinal surgery in March of 2017 just
six months before this incident 18 hours
after the surgery and mr. D'Amato got on
the stand and he said I loved my wife
during this temporary custody hearing
that obviously is a lie he's used to
lying that's what he does as a lobbyist
in New York State and throughout the
nation but why show this video it's a
custody matter involves the children are
you're going too far do you think no not
at all because he has indicated all
along that he's never said a bad word
about his wife and yet he broke his hand
trying to assault her at one point so
she is a victim of domestic violence and
fraud and forgery and this is just going
on and on and on and the court is not
doing anything about this and you're
arguing that the court that essentially
the fix is in that he's got too much
clout there to have a fair trial on this
custody matter well his son-in-law is a
Supreme Court justice on the same bench
where this case is being tried his
daughter is employed or was employed by
the county of Nassau in that case where
Edie Mangano was just invited and
convicted his grandson is an a DA an
assistant district attorney in Nassau
County
so his influence is far and wide
throughout the state throughout the
judiciary he engineered the endorsement
of the courts endorsement of this
particular judge who's trying this
matrimonial case which meant that the
voters had no choice about electing this
judge who was rejected by the voters
three times previously in judicial
elections you filed this lawsuit in
federal court oh not in the state court
right we we've exhausted every
possibility and
in state court for the time being
although there are several appeals that
are pending there but we had to reach
out because there are constitutional and
parental rights that are in jeopardy
here civil rights and parental rights
are in jeopardy her children are being
hurt by what this Court has done to her
since October 5th 2017 and it's
outrageous what's going on
and the name of the courthouse where
this lawsuit has been filed supreme
court well the federal court is in the
Eastern District of New York in the
United States courthouse there and the
state court and the state court is
Supreme Court Nassau County the
courthouse building named well the
federal courthouse is named after
Alphonse D'Amato and he's obviously been
instrumental in creating the judgeships
for many of the people who occupy those
seats in the Eastern District of New
York you don't think very quickly you
can get a fair trial here
I don't know where I'm going to get a
fair trial but I keep trying I want to
have this case the matrimonial case
moved out of Nassau County and before a
different judge obviously we've tried
that we've tried to get stays and so
forth so far we've not succeeded but
we're going to go forward with our
federal action notwithstanding the fact
that I've been disqualified for bogus
reasons in the state Supreme Court
action thomas leo d thank you very much
for being here we're gonna stay on the
story coming up a former top homeland
security official ran beers joins us
live to talk about what in the world is
going on in Washington
we turn now to what's happening in
Washington at the Department of Homeland
Security where President Donald Trump
continues to carry out a purge of
officials that he says are refusing to
follow his directions whose legality
some say is questionable to many it
seemed like a real-life version of some
kind of White House game show you fired
go you're fired
I mean this administration has more
staff turnover than a Walmart on Black
Friday joining us to talk about these
latest developments is ranvir's a former
Acting Secretary of Homeland Security
under the Obama administration and a
longtime public service in both
Republican and Democratic
administrations he's now a member of the
board of governors of the middlee
Institute mr. beers joins us from his
home in Virginia and mr. Burriss thank
you very much for joining us what in the
world is going on in Washington at
Homeland Security that's a very good
question Brian
I mean clearly what's happened here is
that the almost the entire leadership of
this very diverse Department tallied
have been removed or moved we're in a
situation now with an Acting Secretary
and acting deputy secretary the
Department has nine separate components
which are the Goss of DHS of those nine
there are five who have acting heads at
this point in Prague then possibly a six
we'll be leaving from the US citizens
and Immigration Services well we've got
a very good solid civil service staff in
this department to take out the
leadership on such short notice
to move it around is creating the
extraordinary challenge for the
department you know Kevin McAfee has
moved up from CDC to run the department
is a very very capable officer he would
probably have been the commissioner
under a democratic administration had
Lewton won the election that's how I
lead he's regarded on both sides of the
aisle but his experience in Customs and
Border Protection is a far cry from
running a department which is
responsible for cybersecurity is a
stirrer relief the united states coast
guard protecting ports and marine
disasters protecting the president and
other issues i'm not saying he can't do
it I'm just saying it's a huge challenge
and he doesn't have a deputy who's been
there longer than he has been head of
TSA has moved up to be the Acting Deputy
separates well mr. beers oh no it's a
huge bureaucracy what's the impact when
you have all this turmoil at the top
what you have is a career staff trying
to keep the department from running off
the rails and they will do a good job of
maintaining a stable course but what
they won't be able to do is make big
changes in short order because the civil
service bureaucracy is there as
essentially the caretaker but not really
a leadership element of the department
except when they find themselves in
these acting roles and none of these
people who have moved up have been in
those positions before or have been
close to being in those positions in the
last two years of this administration so
basically what you have is the
department without a clear leadership
structure mr. beer is a quick question
for you from the control room they help
you Rhonda moment from Rhonda Schwartz
our executive producer Rhonda Randa
president Trump says that it was under
President Obama that the policy of
separating children began is that
correct information that would have been
under your watch the short answer to
that is there were some separation they
were minor the reasons for them make
sense to most people in terms of safety
insecure
issues that's a far cry from taking
families wholesale coming across the
border I am separating our children from
their parents
Ranbir's thank you so much for joining
us this evening we'll continue to watch
this development your insights are
extremely helpful coming up our shout
out for the reporter who got hired as a
$9 an hour guard at one of the country's
notorious private prisons and came out
with this disturbing undercover video of
what goes on behind those walls
and our shoutout tonight for a
journalist working for Mother Jones
magazine who went undercover in a
potentially very dangerous place inside
a private for-profit prison a place that
it's worked hard to keep journalists and
the public from knowing exactly what's
going on inside their walls the
assignment was to get hired as a guard
inside this privately run prison known
as the wind Correctional Center in
Winfield Louisiana soon I'm gonna be in
there for eight hours a day and then
soon after that I'm gonna be in there
for 12 hours a day
this prison is crazy beyond anything I
ever imagined 1,500 inmates overseen by
guards making $9 an hour mother jones
reporter Shane Bauer was quickly hired
my first day of training he's the head
of training said to us that at CCA we'll
hire anybody she said you know people
people say to say that we're scraping
the bottom of the barrel but we're not
but if you have a driver's license and
are breathing and are willing to work
than were willing to hire you
[Music]
if you really care about yourself please
phone protect yourself inside a place of
chaos and violence all captured on video
by Bauer with a camera hidden in his
watch that he smuggled inside I was
surprised with how kind of bare-bones
the operation was you know there was
very little staff there were you know
maybe twenty five guards for 1,500
prisoners which kind of leads the prison
to be more violence than other prisons
in the state there was an escape while I
was there in the middle of the day he
went up to finish got on roof of the
building the prison staff didn't
actually know that he escaped for two
three hours
not enough people for security and Bauer
says the prison company cut corners on
medical care for the prisoners by
actually my first and the president met
a man who prisoner who had lost his legs
and fingers to gangrene Bauer says the
company is slow to send anyone to an
outside hospital because it has to pay
the bill what you took here don't belong
be yours cover was finally blown when a
photographer for Mother Jones James West
was spotted outside the prison taking
exterior shots at sheriff's department
deputies demanded to see what was on his
camera I think the best time to seize
his camera I will take it we found out
later that someone at the Sheriff's
Department had searched James's video
without a warrant and on that video was
an interview that he had done with me
that day talking about working in the
prison so they were able to kind of
connect that that I was you know
journalists Bauer quickly moved out
calling in his resignation to the prison
company
I'm actually calling because I decided
to resign Bauer's stories and Mother
Jones and a subsequent book got the
attention of the US Department of
Justice and shortly afterwards the Obama
administration announced that they were
going to stop using private prisons in
the federal level this of course is
reversed as soon as Donald Trump became
president so now it's kind of you know
it's back to where it was before all the
more reason that Bowers undercover
reporting is now so important yeah I
mean we have a rich tradition of
undercover journalism in this country
and it's only in the last couple decades
that we haven't seen it as much and I
think that we have a right to see you
know when companies are serving as
public institutions what they're doing
and if they're not gonna allow us access
then we have to figure out how to get it
in a statement the company that ran that
prison at the time now known as core
civic said Bowers conduct was reckless
could have jeopardized safety and
security and that he obtained employment
under false pretenses but Ana's
application Bower did describe himself
as a writer and use the name of the
mother Joran's parent company as his
employer so that seems very much on the
up-and-up most telling the statement did
not address in any way the appalling
conditions Bower discovered inside the
prison which is no longer owned by that
same company so our shout out tonight
for Shane Bauer and Mother Jones for
allowing Americans to see what happens
with important public services and
functions are turned over to companies
whose first priority is to make a profit
it's not a pretty fixture that's our
program for tonight thanks so much for
joining us we'll see you back here again
next week good night